- [Voiceover] Get in there.
Eat his face!
(fast-paced bouncy music)
- Christmas is just around the corner.
So my buddy Christian here is gonna
hold a mistletoe over my head.
We're gonna see how many celebrities
will kiss me on the red carpet.
Think it's gonna be steamy?
- Oh yeah.
- Who's the best kisser of the group?
- Oh, I'm definitely the best at kissing.
- Would you say that
you're like a good kisser?
- Um, I think so, I like kissing.
- Well, I have no complaints, so
let's say yes.
- [Interviewer] That's always
a good thing.
Are there a lot of holiday traditions?
Are you gonna, oh.
Oh my, oh my God, what is?
- Oh.
- What is that?
- It's a --
- Is that marijuana?
(laughter)
- Is that mistletoe?
- Aw.
- I believe that's a mistletoe.
- Oh, mistletoe (laughter).
- What is that, okay!
- Police, police!
- We don't do this in Sweden.
I don't know what that is either.
- I think you put it in your soup.
(laughter)
- I don't know what people do, I'm Jewish.
But I think people kiss.
- Is that true?
- Is it true that I'm Jewish, yeah.
- So what's gonna happen? (laughter)
- I would.
- Yeah, but --
- But, I just wouldn't.
- What do we, do you wanna?
- Oh my God.
- What are we, what are we?
- I'm starting to sweat.
- Tinashe, you better kiss him.
- What if we got like
really, really, really?
- [Voiceover] Just really get in there.
Just get in there.
- Do you wanna hug?
Okay.
- We gotta do a video, man.
- Thank you, Conrad.
- Perfect!
- That's like basically
what you're supposed
to do, right?
- Yeah.
- [Voiceover] Get in there, get involved.
Eat his face!
(laughter)
- That was lovely.
- It was so good!
- Oh, so no kisses today?
- No, no kisses today.
- I don't think so.
- Is it something I did?
- Yeah, a little bit.
- Like top 10 kiss for me.
- Probably top five.
- Top five, wow!
- We can.
(smooching)
(laughter)
- And we have a sax
player, let's get in here.
Let's dance, guys.
- Oh, this is for you
guys, this is a gift.
(slow jazz music)
(laughter)
- What an interview!
- Now he's got red lipstick on.
- The moment is nigh, we are
trying to get One Direction
to kiss me underneath the mistletoe.
Do you think we're gonna get them?
I tried, you know.
One D was here, I tried.
- [Voiceover] What's up?
- [Interviewer] I tried.
- Oh, I'm not gonna kiss you.
- No, I wanted One Direction.
- Oh!